there is a moment in everyone's life
we must make a choice and that the
world's shape our destiny or fight to
become who we're meant to be
throw the parachutes I know
hi my name is danielle shibez oh game
director at eros Montreal you've just
seen the beginning of Shadow the Tomb
Raider which will deliver on Lara cross
defining moment as she raised to stop a
Maya apocalypse bara will have to
confront a brutal jungle environment in
order to survive and even though that
she's more confident and more capable
she will still be outgunned and
outnumbered by Trinity she will have to
use everything she'll learn from the
jungle and use it in order to survive we
call this becoming one with the jungle
let's take a look what this means for
gameplay
jeez
base camps having trouble receiving
Jewish this is up they use the booster
signal
but I got it
attach these together
got the team still has eyes on joining
Maya
we get more light in here got the team
still has eyes on one of my agents
can we spell me a bit about a check-in
with Matisse jerk gives me something to
do
hey you know multis is access code Oh
103 5-3 Mike hey heading over there now
do some backup here
this place is empty body here looks
recent
cards up they can't be gone find out
what's going on
do take point lead the way
maybe there
[Music]
we hope that you like what you've just
seen so much depth to the combat and we
cannot wait to show you more there's new
traversal techniques like rappeling wall
running we even have a full 360-degree
underwater swimming which means full
underwater exploration and survival
we have also one of the biggest hub we
ever created in any Tomb Raider game
featuring a head and city and of course
we have tombs we have more of them and
they're deadlier than ever before but
for now we're gonna leave you with a
video that will give you a taste of what
to expect out of shadow the two mater
and how Lara Croft becomes the Tomb
Raider that she's test them to be
[Music]
[Music]